I was wondering if you knew what this
might be this is so it's a circular
metal metal contraption with teeth on
the inside for just no idea what is that
this is called the Zhu Campinas this is
a Victorian anti-masturbation device
what yeah there's the real one this is
this is a prop that I use for under the
knife that's the real one so what would
happen is if the person got an erection
it would clamp down and obviously kill
the erection pretty quickly can I see
that yeah that's one we made for the
show okay yeah but it's basically yeah
it's similar if you see like the one on
the screen it has device so these they
were trying why were they trying to get
people to stop masturbate so the
Victorians were obsessed with with
masturbation and there's probably a lot
of people out there who know that
Kellogg's cornflakes came out of this
sort of obsession yes to patient please
tell people that story we heard it from
doctor Chris Ryan oh it's so funny well
it's funny in a haha kind of horrifying
way Kellogg was was obsessed with with
masturbation he thought that a lot of
his patients were suffering from all
kinds of mental ailments and physical
ailments because they were masturbating
too much and he thought that a diet
bland in bland and high in fiber would
kind of kill the fire in the belly and
so he invented what became Kellogg's
quarterly extreme but his brother was
the one who commercialized and his
brothers like we should add sugar and
dr. Kellogg was like no people we
masturbating all the time we can't add
sugar you know and they had this like
sweat and Kellogg's cornflakes became
the commercial version with the
delicious sugar added in so that was the
brothers idea it was the brothers idea
to add the sugar and make it sort of
delicious oh yeah oh yeah that's that
was a illustrated by my husband we do
all kinds of did that yeah oh so that's
not original no we read your son and
heir is a becoming a dirty little self
abuser stop all contemptible is this an
actual text from yeah he's a cock lane
in London though
but there is stop all contemptible
onanism what is onanism masturbating and
onanism with the infallible and modestly
surprised jew Campinas so was that a
common thing during the Victorian era so
yeah you get I mean the idea that
masturbating is bad for your health goes
to the 18th century we kind of tend to
think about it is a Victorian obsession
because it becomes more and more
accepted idea in medical terms but it's
bad for you that it's bad for you and
you get these like sort of drawings of
men like languishing on the couch was it
masturbated too much a lot of Jews out
there right now there can relate they
just need the Jew Campinas and and also
there's another one I sent you Jamie I
think the the sort of like looks like a
flaccid penis was another ones is really
high yeah there they came in all shapes
and sizes and oh boy yeah like now it
would probably just be yeah you're
supposed to pee out of that yeah maybe
you could just holes at the end of it
like you have to just that's what that
thing smelled like oh Christ look at
that ball at the bottom with the hook
that seems super uncomfortable
it's in between your legs so it must be
like a hook where you could strap it in
that's like a tie steel cup I don't know
who's coming on the show afterwards but
they got a lot of functions oh good news
is Ron is a hilarious comedian so we're
all good we might have to redo the
entire show just with Ron yeah just
showing me I'll just leave these objects
behind and you had the copper so it's so
gross in fact you to pee out of those
look like a spaghetti strainer at the
end of it I knew I thought you know when
I was gonna show I'm like what can I
bring joe rogan that's gonna you know
stimulate the conversation and the anti
masturbation device so he's a crowd
pleaser well with men he's an issue a
fascination they thought that it was
causing all these
ailment
they thought I was causing all these
different problems yeah and graham
crackers as well come out of that so
Reverend Graham was also obsessed with
masturbation just like how long and so
he created this sort of dry tasteless
biscuit so everybody you know crumbling
them into there Wow little did he know
that someone invent s'mores now you know
I don't know if it works if people feel
like that that's helping them with their
masturbation problems but hey leave a
comment what's just crazy that people
didn't most people have no idea that
that was the origin of this funny you
know there's there's so many like
Listerine graham crackers Kellogg
cornflakes all this kind of stuff that
that has sort of a medical background
and wasn't there a medical background in
the term hysterical that hysterical was
related to women yeah the idea that the
wanders like that the female womb was
like an animal of which you know and it
would move around the body and so you
they would even do things like they
would smoke it back into place they'd
put like smoke they would put like
incense and all kinds of things to kind
of like get it like coax it back into
place I can't even imagine the people
are gonna start following me after this
but there was there was a time where
women would go to the doctor to get
stimulated as well right is that true
this is like a little bit out of my
expertise I think that's been proven to
be false actually um but but there was I
believe and I could be wrong on this
that there was a Victorian idea that a
woman had to orgasm in order to become
pregnant yes so that was that was an
important part of it I wasn't just a
Victorian thing I'm pretty sure they
taught me that in high school you want
to get a woman pregnant was part of the
idea was part of the male orgasming
inside the woman was what led to her
having an orgasm which would led to her
getting pregnant
that is weird well there was there was -
might have completely removed correctly
again so I was probably 15 at the time
oh well there you go but there was there
was someone um I think it was like a
senator Congress I live in the UK now so
I'm not as to date with with all the
crazy stuff going on over here
um but I think there was like a senator
who said this again this idea that a
woman had to like orgasm it meeting
undermining the idea that you couldn't
be raped right unless you had an orgasm
which was a Victorian I remember leave
yeah I think that was really recently
yeah I think it was like in the last
year like I really do Ramin I should
just be like in the background popping
up and like I could have like a sign
that says 18th century or 19th that you
know let's where did that idea come from
originally and that's I do have this
weird weird vague memory that that was
the way that you were taught Catalan but
it's it's too weird I don't remember
I know it's it's too vague you know it
does sound like I now I picture you went
to like a really Victorian school it's a
place called Newton south and it's
suburb of Boston really nice cool your
sex I'm not sure if that was they did
smack our hands oh it caught us
masturbate so but why were people so
obsessed with that while they observe
cells self pleasuring yeah and I think
that again you know you look at that
sort of buttoned up Victorian mentality
can I put like dresses over the legs of
pianos and chairs and stuff like that I
don't know about that I think they did
[Music]
it might be more bullshit than I
remember but I do remember something
like this before I just did torch it
right it says it's not okay but it is oh
okay you know what I remember where I
heard it from I heard it from Terence
Mckenna
it was one of the things he talked about
during one of his his speeches that's
right we did we did fact check that I
mean we like to think that that the past
is really different from us which it is
in some ways but you know again like we
still share some similar fears and